president chumps point man for the
crisis in Venezuela says disputed
president Nicolas Maduro eventually will
fall Russia is criticizing the US
tonight for what it calls a cynical
campaign to oust the legitimate
government of Venezuela the State
Department correspondent rich Edson has
the story
contested Venezuelan president Nicolas
Maduro as vice president is in Russia
Russia supports Maduro and claims the
United States may use military force in
Venezuela
Shoeless motion and the Trump
administration says all options are on
the table I don't want to Telegraph our
punches to the regime I would just say
the people who are talking about an
American military action are the regime
or the Russians officials stress they
are pursuing a peaceful transition that
means economic pressure for now the US
has announced it is revoking the visas
of nearly 50 Maduro aligned officials
and their families and sanctioning
several top military and security
officials I can't predict the day that
Maduro falls and leaves Venezuela and it
may be that three days before people
will be saying oh the administration
policy has failed and then BOOM there he
goes and that day will come
Maduro has even invited special envoy to
Venezuela Elliott Abrams to meet with
him in an interview with Fox News Abrams
says he's never met with Maduro and
rejected his invitation it's a mistake
to allow them to turn it into some kind
of battle between the u.s. and and
Maduro Abrams is coordinating with
opposition leader Juan Y dough
who I know is in Paraguay after leaving
Venezuela last week in defiance of a
court order to join aid convoys in
Colombia and has met with leaders in
Brazil I have received threats to my
person and my family but threats of
being imprisoned as well by the Maduro
regime even so that will not prevent my
return to Venezuela this weekend at the
very latest Monday abram says there will
be a big reaction in venezuela and
internationally if authorities arrest
guido while testifying about the
administration's venezuela strategy two
weeks ago Abrams met sharp criticism
from freshman congresswoman Ilhan Omar
that is a ridiculous question about yes
or no no I I am NOT going to respond to
that kind of personal attack Abram says
he and the congresswoman have not spoken
since I
really don't know what that was all
about you would have to ask that the
congresswoman what her what her intent
was in that colloquy the administration
has also warned Cuba over its support of
Nicolas Maduro Abrams refused to say if
officials were considering sanctions
against the Cuban government though he
noted the administration is always
thinking about the u.s. relationship
with Cuba
Shannon Richardson at the State
Department thank you